hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my Game of Thrones episode 5 video
some really cool book moments done in
slightly different ways so I'll explain
what the differences are as we work
through WTF moments this week I'm giving
away signed copies of feast for crows
and Dance with Dragons so all you have
to do then to giveaway is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
I'll announce the winner in my Q&A
tomorrow so careful for spoilers if you
haven't seen the episode yet I'm gonna
do top 7 moments just to give me a
little extra room just like last week so
here we go number 7 the death of
Barristan Selmy Barristan the bold this
is a real bummer so supposedly the actor
was doing interviews last week talking
about being dead so there were some
minor spoilers especially with the promo
they released everyone knew going into
this season that they'd be killing a
character that's still alive in the
books so this is one of the big points
of divergence for the show Barristan
Selmy is gonna be a POV chapter and wins
a winner so if you're a huge Barristan
Selmy fan just hold your breath till the
book is released and you'll be fine
isn't it interesting how his dart just
like slowly walks in the background as
Daenerys is ruminating on his death he
prostrated himself so much in this
episode that there has got to be
something going on with this character a
lot of people think that this woman
might be the harpy because in the books
the biggest theory is is that the green
Grace is the harpy but the green grace
isn't on the TV show they don't have
that character so they're doing
something different his dark could still
turn out to be the harpy or the person
controlling the harpies or it could be a
non-issue on the show there is now a
gaping hole in Daenerys his circle of
advisers and a actually causes some
problems during the episode because
Daenerys needs a lot of help
Daenerys needing advisors also kind of
works well with maester aemon
feeling so sorry for her that was
another big book-related moment in the
episode in the books maester aemon has a
speech just like this when he's talking
to Sam well about Daenerys being alone
but he feels like he is too old to go
help her there was a subtle shout-out to
the Citadel in Old Town so we could be
seeing that on the show just in case I'm
gonna wait to talk about that as
expected Samwell is like slowly learning
more about the White Walkers and Stannis
is really interested in that which i
think is really cool
I loved that he gave him that shout out
I hear you killed a white Walker he also
gave his dad a big shout out it just
shows you that it's that much easier to
get Stannis's respect than it is to get
a hug from him on to number 6 Daenerys
rounds up all the leaders in the noble
houses of murine this is one of the
first moments in the episode where they
honor a moment from the books by doing
something slightly different
Quinton Martell has a minor storyline in
the books but the show isn't doing him I
think this moment here with this person
getting roasted by one of the nurses
dragons is homage to his storyline in
the books there were a number of other
moments in the episode that did things
like that so that's what I think this is
think of this is like a Quentyn Martell
scene on to number 5 Jon Snow wants to
bring the wildlings from hardhome down
to the wall maester aemon gives them a
little bit of a bump kill the boy so
that the man can live this is part of
the larger arc of Jon Snow learning to
be a leader the same thing is happening
with Daenerys of murine you know she's
learning to be a queen maester aemon
tells him the job is gonna suck you
could also say the same for Daenerys
being queen of all those people
it is totally gonna suck for her the
title killed the boy was one of the best
things about the episode you you could
apply it in metaphorical ways to what's
going on with Jon Snow he needs to kill
the boy inside him and you could apply
it in a literal context Ramsay Bolton
wants to kill the boy inside fat Walda
then you have all it here who absolutely
hates the fact that Jon Snow is doing
this with the wildlings at hardhome
there's no way Jon is gonna kill all
eight but that doesn't mean that he's
not gonna die somehow kill the boy and
to be clear Olly is actually mistaken
the Thins are the ones that killed his
family they live way up here north of
where the free folk live genealogically
they're a completely separate group
their people are actually more
genetically pure descendants of the
first men they didn't interbreed as much
with people from other places in the
world on to number four Sansa and Theon
reunion so now we kind of see where the
Miranda plot is going she is up
greyscale creek without a paddle
so what can she do but create chaos the
place where she met Sansa the the broken
Tower that's actually the place where
brain got pushed out the window by Jamie
because twincest there were so many meta
moments in this scene too it's like
you're thinking back about that season
one moment then you're thinking about
what the servant woman said to Sansa you
know light a candle at the top if you
need help which ties to the Brienne
storyline where she's hiding out in
winter town near Winterfell
trying to help Sansa it's really hard to
tell where reek storyline is going right
now I think he's genuinely afraid for
her her emotions are much more complex
like just way
of anger just wash over her the minute
she recognizes him what I'm really
hoping to see is say like Theon kill
Ramsay to save Sansa and then Sansa does
something to kill freak it would be
really fun to to see Sansa push Miranda
out the window that bran got pushed out
of the minute they both looked up at
that window I just thought somebody has
to get pushed out of that this season so
Miranda mission accomplished there is
now chaos wreak is probably going to try
and do something to atone for what he
did Sansa who is acquitting herself
quite nicely amongst all our enemies is
probably just gonna see what she can do
to survive and then you have Brienne
who's going to try and help out too so
you have like all these things at
Winterfell working together and now
there's actually some added chaos
because fat Waldo's pregnant with a boy
on to number three Ramsay versus his
unborn brother so many funny moments
between Ramsay and his father when they
had that scene I'm your heir until
someone better comes along
suddenly the title kill the boy takes on
a more literal context I definitely
think that Ramsay's gonna try and do
something to fat Walda I think ruses
speech about Ramsay's mother explains
why the show wants you to think of him
as a villain that is if you didn't think
the red wedding made him a villain it's
just you know characters kill other
characters it doesn't necessarily mean
that Game of Thrones as a show has a
true hero in a true villain but when a
character like this fondly remembers
raping a peasant woman then almost
killing her when she brought their baby
to his gate there can be no doubt that
this character has to die in a really
terrible way the North remembers maybe
someone will catch him on the [ __ ]
wouldn't it be funny if Ramsay pulled
the tyrion and killed fat Walda and his
father he's the heir right now so he'd
be good to go if they were both dead on
to number two Daenerys reopens the
fighting pits and tells his door that
she is going to marry him this is
another small departure from the books
so Daenerys does reopen the fighting
pits and she does get betrothed to
hizdahr but it's more of a choice put to
her in the books the show is just giving
her a little more agency miss and I says
that she always relies on her advisors
in the books she does have like a lot
more people advising her I like the way
the show is doing this is just showing
that Daenerys is choosing to enter this
eyes open in the book she knows she has
to marry
hizdahr but she's much more reluctant
about it on the show it looks like she's
gonna dominate him and finally my number
one WTF moment Tyrion in sir Jorah do
the young grift storyline in old Valyria
there's a whole lot of meta things going
on with this
Tyrion Jorah seen at the end first they
go into the ruins of old Valyria which
isn't something that the books does so
that's a change but it's really fun
change it's like showing us the lands of
always winter last season that's the way
I thought about that scene showing us a
place that they talk about in the books
but that we don't actually go to in the
books the stone men were also part of
that in the books what this is basically
taking the place of is the young grift
storyline so Tyrion is traveling with
the young Griff characters on the shy
maid down the Rhoyne he falls in in Jon
connington Yanks him out just like Sir
George did but in the process contracts
greyscale just like jor did so Sir Jorah
is kind of taking that from Jon
connington storyline huge WTF and Tyrion
craps his pants when he sees drogon
flying overhead he also has a vision of
drogon in the books but it's in a
slightly different context since we
don't know if Jorah and Tyrion are going
to make it to marine unscathed I'm not
gonna go too deep into his storyline
from the books I'll just wait till after
next week well to see I know there's a
lot of you asking you know what is
greyscale how does it work really like
your skin and your internal organs like
your soft tissues they all just Harden
so that it looks like stone so like as
your internal organs start to stone over
so to speak you slowly lose the ability
to function your body's to start
shutting down so when they say stone
minute Valyria think of it as being like
a really serious version of a leper
colony you can't touch anyone or you'll
give it to them so just go over here by
yourselves and leave us alone
the really fun thing though about them
going to the ruins of Valyria is as
Tyrion has an uncle one of Thailand's
brothers that went to the ruins of
Valyria looking for the ancestral blade
of the Lannisters it's called bright
roar and his uncle was never seen again
I was a little disappointed he didn't
get a shout out in the episode but but I
totally understand them not doing it so
here's my big question for you guys what
was your favorite moment from the
episode and what do you think is gonna
happen to Sir Jorah now that he has
greyscale Stannis explained to Shireen
that he was able to halt the progress of
the greyscale it's scarred shereen's
face for
life but he was able to stop it before
it killed her so Jorah isn't necessarily
sentenced to death as much as they're
changing a bunch of stuff from the books
you know you can see how there were like
specific moments where they were trying
to do book things even though they did
them in slightly different ways I feel
like they've done a good job so far
building momentum with each episode each
new week things have gotten
progressively crazier and crazier
until finally we're in old Valyria we
see greyscale and we see drogon who is
freaking huge you guys can let me know
whether you agree you know do you feel
like they're building momentum with each
episode sometimes they don't always
stick the landing like you know there's
always big moments in the finales but
sometimes non finale episodes just come
together as a whole and end up being a
little bit better than actual finales so
don't forget about the book giveaway
I'll announce the winner of that
tomorrow my Q&A video while you wait for
that to post you can click here to learn
all about lyanna stark's history and you
can click here for last week's episode
thank you so much watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tomorrow
[Music]